à la ferme de cours simon la nature est
reine et la petite reine et le mode de
déplacement privilégié des clients
il faut dire que ce village vacances du
loir-et-cher bénéficient de l'écolabel
la garantie d'un respect exigeant de
l'environnement alors au petit déjeuner
ce sont forcément des produits du
terroir à la carte préfèrent consommer
les produits locaux
non c'est la santé que de produire des
produits importés on ne connaît pas bien
l'origine n'a choisi un peu à cause du
coc vide aussi parce que on pensait
aller dans le sud
et puis tout a été annulée puis tout
contre caen s'est dit tiens on va
découvrir une région qu'on connaissait
pas la sologne comme cadre de vacances
pour un tourisme vert pour être éco
labellisés la ferme de courcy monde doit
respecter des normes strictes comme la
gestion et le tri des déchets ou encore
la réduction de la consommation
d'énergie
ça représente plus de temps de réflexion
sur le choix des fournisseurs sur le
travail plus en amont alors évidemment
il ya un coup dès qu'on dit le mot
écologie dès qu'on dit le mot bio on se
dit que ça coûte toujours un peu plus
cher si on travaille correctement avec
des fournisseurs locaux c'est pas
forcément un budget beaucoup plus élevé
sur le long terme et pourtant seuls 11
hébergements touristiques sont
certifiées par l'ecolabel ans entre val
de loire parmi eux sept hôtels en pleine
zone urbaine où aller visiter les
chambres de l'étiquette ap val de loire
et on va repérer avec vous les quelques
éléments qui permettent d'identifier
effectivement la politique
environnementale qu'on a mis en place
pour obtenir l'écolabel voilà c'est par
là bas dans les chambres pas de
gaspillage le client et sensibiliser à
l'économie de chauffage l'eau est aussi
un bien précieux à utiliser avec
parcimonie
à l'extérieur un récupérateur d'eau de
pluie a même été installé pour
l'arrosage du jardin un jardin où les
déchets sont compostés et les clients
sont parfaitement assorti à ce décor ce
la ton vélo solaire ils ont les
mêmes valeurs que nous je pense même
plus que nous non mais c'est tout ce
qu'on défende ont défendu voyage propre
du voyage respectueux de l'environnement
en essayant de faire le moins de déchets
et puis et puis en utilisant pas de
courant juste soleil donc finalement
c'est exactement conditions son sens
chez nous quoi tout simplement des
valeurs de développement durable qui
progresse même si en matière de tourisme
vert il y a encore des efforts à faire
aujourd'hui les vacances coûte encore
cher à la planète
elles sont responsables de huit pour
cent des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre